fuir l'intensité croissante des combats
au départ de prokop ski dans la région
de donetsk
un train évacue chaque jour des
personnes vers la ville de lviv dans
l'ouest de l'ukraine
en ce moment nous évacuons les personnes
à mobilité réduite les malades les
handicapés les personnes âgées nous
prônons tout le monde
je suis parti parce qu'il ya eu des
frappes ces quatre derniers jours qui
était très proche de nous c'est
maintenant effrayant de vivre dans sa
propre maison
j'ai dû par
le dombass dans l'est du pays est devenu
la cible prioritaire de la russie
l'armée tous poursuit sa progression
versier verrou donetsk des bombardements
constants alors que des dizaines de
milliers de civils seraient toujours
présents dans la région le président
américain a annoncé mercredi une
nouvelle aide militaire d'un montant
d'un milliard de dollars un geste salué
par le président ukrainien je suis
reconnaissante pour ce soutien il est
particulièrement important pour notre
défense dans la région orientale du don
en grâce après plus de 100 jours de
guerre kiev a exhorté ses combattants à
tenir le coup de son côté washington a
appelé ses alliés intensifier leurs
livraisons d'armes en ukraine